okay for people joining this live stream
we're starting a little bit late here
uh we are doing the first of a total of
four
live streams for today um we are
continuing with looking at visualization
functionality
for version 12.3 of language
so where have we got to before uh
we did vector geo psi and
axis can we look at the docs for
axis object for
one moment just to
make one last pass through the set of
option names
this will still be experimental for 12
years experimental
and you know some of the stuff you know
may get you know
futurized you know before it goes out
the door so that depending on
how far implementation is solid and
whatnot
um okay
and so we're
introducing the you know axis object
referee sort of syntax which is the
bottom half of that table
right well i like it very much but i
think what you should say with that
horizontal thing
at the top
i mean that's equivalent to infinite
line
you know
um
no without i guess
through y equals y zero and then um
from x from zero to one or something
okay well no it's not from zero to one
it's just going to follow whatever the x
plot range is
in that graphic no it's
it's an infinite line isn't it this one
here is an infinite line
infinite horizontal line okay so it
doesn't matter where
pt2 is sometimes it's in the right
vector direction
right so it doesn't matter that it's
that's the plot range
right no what i mean is that it doesn't
go from zero to one
you know so if if you have it's an
infinite line all the infinite line has
a direction
see what i'm saying yes
so mathematically it's equivalent to
if i'm not misunderstanding this no i
think you are misunderstanding
okay well let's let's make let's clarify
my misunderstanding then
okay do a plot okay so listen listen
this is what i think it is
am i wrong that's what horizontal comma
y 0
is equivalent to that
yes i guess that's equivalent to that
where zero and one are you know
arbitrary but yes arbitrary
right unit vector okay all right that's
all i was saying
it's not very profound okay gotcha okay
that i can say
i mean somewhere you could you should
say that but i mean it's my
understanding so here
um i am wondering a bit
hmm i'm not completely convinced about
this syntax being worth having and i'm
kind of thinking that i that it would be
a better syntax just say
horizontal arrow y0 that that would be a
bit cleaner
and if you want this kind of thing you
just use a line
because you're not saving any characters
really here
are you you're not saving characters
you're you know
if you say horizontal or vertical you
know there's
no room for your
calculation of things introduced some
numeric error and now it's
not vertical by ten to the minus
sixteenth or something
actually okay all right fine but okay
another question
if i wrap style around this line and say
red
i assume it's still going to work
um i mean actually it could work
it'd be much better to put the style
around the axis object i understand it
would be
i mean i don't think that works with
like the two barrow syntax
yeah it doesn't work with arrow okay
could it can generate a sentient error
message
i actually don't know what it does okay
well it's something
i mean the issue is that i mean so while
you can specify a line or whatever
you know once you i mean if you have a
style wrapper then you're sort of
getting into the case where somebody
says axis object of
science complicated yeah okay i
understand you're off the hook there
so long as there's a sentient error
message yep
okay what else should i be looking at
here um i just want to run through the
option names real quick because we
which option names down here yep right
there um
take direction
i need to update the text on the right
hand side of that table but
um what are the values to take direction
uh they're in a table from farther down
um inward outward
left right up down okay
that sort of thing sounds nice to me
um no for some reason i'm i'm
reminded of lime tick disease
[Laughter]
what what does inward mean what's
inward over line the center of the
graphic
what remember this is
this is which way the text what happens
if you want
ticks that slice and access
but you shouldn't have to know about the
whole graphic to know which side you're
putting the fix on
i mean roger in any particular case it
will be
i think be fairly clear which one you
want
parallel access plot it's going to be
i'm thinking of a mechanical diagram
where you have lots of local coordinate
systems coordinate frames
that you want to draw
in insets what happens if this thing is
an inset
um it's i mean if it's inside an inset
then it's inside a graphic inside the
inset
and it will be resolved you know
relative to that insect graphic
yeah at the end set in inset is quite
the container it's
it shouldn't leak leak anything
uh maybe a more general version of
roger's question is are there bret are
there
places where some of these values are
undefined
i mean is there are undefined for
horizontal axes
is inside defined when you're spiraling
all the way around the
plot or something
so there are cases where you know
it may not make sense um in which case
i mean i think we can still have
sensible fallback behavior
you know so if you have a horizontal
axis and you say tick direction goes to
right
i mean that's i think it's undefined i
mean i think it's
does left and right work those are the
things that are low
local that doesn't refer to a global
object
so so left and right in the new one
are literal left and right visual you
know as opposed to the
you know sort of relative to moving
along the axis which
sort of confuses everybody
what why is that confusing all the
computational geometry is built on that
idea
okay listen listen i have a more
practical question what happens if you
want
ticks that slice and access uh tick
direction center
what is why is this not called tick
positioning
um we discussed that
friday and we decided against it and i
don't remember exactly yeah so tick
label
i think the reason for tick positioning
not doing tick positioning
is that we also have tick positions
which is where the ticks are on the axis
i think brett is right we were yeah
that's right that's what we were talking
about i remember the overlap yeah
but take label positioning
is positioned relative to the axis
or relative to the pick so sorry tick
label positioning is relative to the
tick yes
right so it's got the tick has a as a
head and a tail presumably
yes you called them bass and tip okay
the other day but
um okay all right so
but what i didn't really internalize
this tick direction could be center
right in which case the
tick label positioning still needs
resolved in that case well
one thing to do would be to call it
inward outward
the tick direction inward outward
which defines which way round it's going
in other words it it goes to the inward
side and then
then goes back goes to the outward side
you get what i'm saying not quite
rather than saying center right have the
setting for tick direction
in that case be tick direction arrow
ah the string inward outward right
inward outward
which then defines a direction right so
inward goes
from the axis inward and inward outward
goes from from the axis to the outward
and then to the inward
and that defines you know plausibly
defines a
head and tail so to return to roger's
point we've we've moved from
having a direction oriented along the
axis to a direction that's oriented
along the tick
what do you mean i mean no but this is
i mean roger's point was if you're
looking down the axis
you go left or right to make the tick
right my claim is that it's absolutely
incomprehensible
well i i i mean i understand i
understand the difficulty i'm not fully
excited with roger here but
but you're doing the same sort of thing
here you're looking down the tick to
figure out you know
uh near or far base or tip sure but i
think that's more
more obvious than going
um um
you know then doing this left right
thing going down
the the axis
i think this is fine but i would
recommend that you allow inward outward
as a definition here and center it's a
little weird
it is a little bit weird for a direction
right it's a little weird so
you know i think you can support left
right and center if you want to let's
see what they feel like but i think
that inward outward is a better thing
even though it requires global
information
right i was also just contemplating tick
direction goes to all
and then i had the mental image of like
a little starburst
yeah that's what i that's what i was
imagining too i don't think that
that i don't think that cuts it okay uh
blank stick labels go ahead i don't even
know what the inward output is
let's say you have a centered axis
what do you mean a centered axis you
know like the axis is
is it doesn't really well okay we choose
one
and then we choose it consistently
does it go left to right
it depends on you know which exit is it
is
i mean then for tick positioning the
only frustrating thing
okay so here's a question take label
positioning
could it directly be called be told
inward rather than base or tip
it could just be told inward put me on
the inward side it reminds me of the you
know leeward side and
i don't know you know sailing or
something
you know put me on the side that is uh
inward you go do you get what i'm saying
i mean i think probably it can
i mean we can reuse a lot of the same
you know keywords as for
tick direction i think so um i think
that will be useful
you know as a practical matter because
if you've got an access to vertical
access
and it's like uh you know
drat i i don't know whether it's the
base or the tip but i want it on the
left
they just say left we're done right
this is what i think we should do i
think this is going to work okay
okay uh
okay tick label orientation how can
orientation be none
anything can be done but no no how can
orientation be none what does it mean
it means that we haven't done any
special orientation to the tick label
then it should be automatic
i mean the concern i have
i mean i think we should sound automatic
too
i mean yeah i think you know it's
detection and avoidance
i see yeah
well then what does it do by default
by default label orientation is just
horizontal
then why don't we just say horizontal
okay we'll do
okay okay
good solution um
okay looks okay to me otherwise what
else and tick style we're reusing the
symbol from graphics is the name
um
okay
oh boy x style y style oh i see we're
just reusing the name
because that's only for a single axis
object right
okay and by the way i assume that the
cloud team
is able to take access objects and
render them properly in the cloud that
they're just translated somewhere that
compiled into regular primitives
correct i haven't tried it recently on
cloud
but possibly it'll just bitmap for the
time being but
i mean because i mean axes in general
tend to
yeah are are the faculty for them i
understand that
okay anything else we need to look at
here i don't think so i think
everything else is lots of tables to
say what settings are and some of them
will get illustrations and
right okay is there a future
palette for all of these things
i mean by future palettes well i mean is
it better is it easier if you say i want
my text to look like that
i mean i i was thinking about whether
you know eventually we might end up with
sort of a plot theme
you know sort of for axes
um i see what you're saying well you
might want to look at your plot themes
whether you want to change
the tickery what one could imagine
also a zoo of visualization tools
that uh you know like we have drawing
tools
in a certain context right now um
that i mean you know people have of
course
have often expressed the interest in
being able to
to do certain things already you know
painting and zooming and that sort of
thing and
and this sort of thing might fit in that
uh collection of
tools which collection of tools sorry
the visualization tools
i see a thing which would be very
different from i mean
similar in concept but different in
content than drawing tools
i see a thing which says i've got this
thing add an access here do this do that
yeah right i think that'll be access or
change the labels
i think it'll be very nice yeah yeah but
but something that's friendly with
our you know with our visualization
functions so it doesn't get
boggled by i don't know you know a
multi-function plot or
something like that well quite and i
mean something which also
would return something which just has
some option tweaks and doesn't hasn't
splattered the whole thing into
line premises yeah yeah well this will
very much help with that okay but this
is a good thing i mean the fact that
it's this complicated kind of justifies
why it's taken us 30 years to do this
um but good good stuff all right let's
keep going
yep let's look at the categorical
scales okay um
and so this is not for 12.3 this is just
um work that you know
is ongoing for post 12 3.
okay so the issue is
you are mapping apple pair grape
to coordinates correct
and so
okay what's the relationship between
this kind of scale
and scaling functions and i mean this
will be a very nice thing to fix up
is the date list plot scaling function
story
right because in a sense dateless plot
is another kind of scaling function
and maybe we should exactly and if we if
we're making it
and particularly as as jose works more
on time datums and things
it becomes much more directly you know a
coordinate system story
so it'd be nice to have a scaling
function that says you know date or
something like that
just like absolutely and there's
multiple
types of potential date scaling
functions
yes i agree um including things where
you have for example
you know the weak and then you have a
different tick or something you know for
every
you know you see what i'm saying for
every where the ticks go
is also an issue but you know do you
have a tick every sunday and things like
that
right yeah okay i mean but you have
sort of datelist plot which is a
continuous
time axis and then you have things like
the f
you know like trading charts where
it's a more discreet thing and you know
we don't care about
saturdays and sundays and christmas and
yeah and i don't know how they compress
right right did they have real time or
do you have a
leave where you leave a gap or do you
compress them into trading days
okay so i think i understand what this
is doing
nominal scale access to remove holiday
weekend gaps so how did it know to do
that
i mean in that case it just i mean it
you basically did a you know delete
you know it looked at all the dates
and just mapped you know the first state
to one the second date to two
etc etc etc
okay but i mean so for example if
there's an epilogue to be given here
i mean that's one of the issues in
dateless plot if you want to superimpose
some other plot
on the datelist plot it's kind of
complicated to know what the coordinate
system that you're supposed to use is
right um okay let's take a quick look at
what you're looking at here so this
is so if i said nominal scale
alphabet for example
which is basically what that is right
that would map
i mean arguably you should just do that
you should have this
abcd rather than having a because then
it would be clearer what was going on
this is what i'm saying
so what you're saying is if i say here
alphabet
and i say here to lowercase
okay that does its thing
okay
it's kind of nice actually it's kind of
nice
okay so what this is doing is it's
effectively mapping
it just has a list there so a nominal
scale
is just a it's kind of like a list scale
i don't know whether nominal is the
right i mean nominal
strikes me as kind of uh
you know space program speak for
so nominal is yeah but
okay the two types of categorical scales
there's nominal and
or nominal the only thing you can know
is where the two objects are the same or
not
ordinal you also have an order
right so nominal it has to be resca re
you have to be able to define the
ordering
and uh ethernet live stream is is
mentioning
lexicographic ordering and alphabetical
ordering and so on which are not
unreasonable well let's look at how
ordinal scale works
uh that's not the kind of ordering
yes it is the kind of ordering we're
talking about if we've got a bunch of
coordinates
it is absolutely i mean there's an order
relation between them right
right but you say what it is yes
what is this but here it's finite we
store the order what is what is borg
rp what does that mean this is
psychological
uh the it's the amount of exertion that
okay so by the way we've got a bunch of
background noise which would be
good to not have um but so so this thing
if i evaluate that thing will i see what
it is
no arguably that should evaluate
because what that is if i'm not mistaken
is
um a i mean that's a bunch of
strings isn't it yes
so it should evaluate to that what is
the
the literal form of this
ordering of categorical values so it's a
bunch of strings
and this is mapping to a numerical scale
so in other words in the case that you
have the alphabet
the ordinal and nominal cases would
agree
yes right i mean
although it might be the case that if
you know if you were playing around with
stu or something
then on the nominal scale if you've
given the whole alphabet those will be
up in the upper reaches
whereas here what will be the actual
y-coordinate or x-coordinate or whatever
it is
let's say i say ordinal scale
and so you're not mentioning in this
documentation yet
uh the the name scales right
right and i
i don't know that you know we'll
necessarily include the name scales
oh i like the name skills i think i
think again it's it's
yet another of these micro repository
stories
probably more than the you know other
ones which other ones
well i was watching the geometry
recording last night um
and so like you were looking at the
surface
um material shading
ones yeah yeah and i mean to some extent
you know there's a lot of ordinal scales
and everybody's is different
i understand that i think there's an
interesting question how it relates to
our unit system
because i think that's super interesting
well if we can do something you know
what does it do with quantities what is
the relationship between an
ordinal i mean and should these ordinal
values for this
borg whatever it is scale be
entities of some kind have you talked to
that team at all about this
not about that no i think that would be
an interesting possibility i think if
these were entities
we get to do all kinds of cool things
with them because then
then like i've talked to them and so
this is
stuff that they encountered that sort of
left on the cutting board
and you know so there's some
psychophysics scales that come into here
okay i'll change to a diamond
sorry i talked to them and yeah
they've uh they don't know what to do
with it
particularly so for instance there's
like most scales of hardness for
instance
yep um and so
there are these scales all over the
place but you can't convert
um so i think that there um
well we don't know how to convert i've
yet no but we certainly can do relations
you know is diamond harder than graphite
or something
yeah so that's that's what i don't know
exactly how this is going to flow
into the rest of the system over time
because i think we need to explore
more than one way yeah well i agree but
i i think that
okay so first point is
scales i mean to me there's all kinds of
logic that you can do with these kinds
of ordinal scales
and we should be able to do it and
that's very very interesting and it
reminds me a little bit of temporal lobe
sort of agree
but there are many ways that you can
take it for instance one direction to
take it is to have
kind of like like categorical data sets
very efficient very large scale
and then there's a bunch of things you
can do you can leverage this order
business should we be able to sort
according to it should we be able to
compare should we know
things exactly exactly i think that many
many potential directions
i just you know so i've mapped out some
of this but i think that
the easiest the best way to start is
with visualization
um that's how i'm going to get this kind
of data from
forms from databases from
i understand that but let let's have one
design meeting
to just talk about how to do these
because i think there are a bunch of
ideas
that maybe no no we can i don't think
it's any urge i mean we can do that as
soon as this release is over
no that's fine fine but i mean my my
initial take would be
that these should be entities and that
the that those entities should have
features like
if you say extremely hard greater than
hard
it should just give true right there are
other things that are typical like a
likert scale
is another super common scale what's
going on everywhere
a leica l-i-k-e-r-t
the heck is that look it up
i never heard of it it's the you know
are you dissatisfied or you know very
dissatisfied
oh all the things with smiley faces
yeah sometimes or yeah yeah
so likert scales comes up all the time
in
in in you know in medical tests and
psychological teams no i just never
heard the name for it i'm well aware of
the test types
okay and then there's a whole literature
of how to design scales too because
that's part of what you do when you
design experiments and design
um protocols basically
like treatment protocols like you can
self-diagnose some
yeah yeah right but depression is one of
those
examples right right
okay i mean i suppose we also have
things like star ratings and so on
um yeah
and then you have product ratings so we
i brought up a little bit last time
you know like egg ratings so a lot of
those classifications
and rates i mean um they ordered
came up to facilitate trading so
bonds for instance have ratings yeah
right um then you can
trade bonds but eggs do too and meat
do and yeah but so the thing that's
interesting from a sort of computational
language point of view
is you say i'm allowed in my portfolio
any bond that is more than such and such
rated
right and then that should be
the test right right
you know do at least you know
10 minutes of hard exercise per day
okay well if it's extremely hard then
you're you know you're not
on an ordinal scale extremely hard is
equivalent to hard
for that purpose
okay this is very interesting i mean i
haven't yes
it seems to me it's a whole world that
opens up for us that we have
somehow not seen before yeah
well it's question of what you know in
the world of order relations there's a
certain set of things you can compute
and it reminds me of temporal logic to
some extent
yeah but you start being able to ask for
example
you know what are i mean in this case
because they're discreet things it's
like
what are all entities you know uh
bigger than me so to speak or
right or for example here's another
example if you have a bucket
of things that say very light hard
extremely hard how does that compare
with some other
you know what can you say about it
relative to some other bucket
and that's like vector comparisons and
so on yes
i mean these ones are
total orders the ones that we have here
but yeah if you have product sets the
question is
you know how you do right so it's like
vector greater than
sort of except the the the vector
greater than that we have
are for dimensionals yeah i understand
right yeah okay this is very interesting
all right okay
um so we just wanted to bring it up get
your
initial take on it and where you think
yeah i think that the main thing is the
intersection with entities which seems
like a really intersectional entities
and the use of a you know
and and they this will be you know
but because the way that this comes in
as scaling functions
this will dramatically sort of scale up
the kinds of things that can be
visualized in the data visualization
functions
sure because you can imagine having a
contour plot 3d with categorical and
date axes and stuff
yeah it's great
very good very nice all right i think i
have to move on to the next
um also live stream for folks who are
i'm into that and i'll see you there in
a few minutes